finally making a video on batch
rendering so for those of you learning
OpenGL or graphics programming in
general you've probably heard of
something called batching or batch
rendering and if you haven't well you've
come to the right place because it's an
incredibly useful rendering technique
now a batch rendering itself is kind of
difficult to define precisely because it
could refer to a number of different
things and it absolutely ranges in
complexity from something really simple
that you could just write in a couple of
minutes to something that is much
greater and part of a larger system what
we're going to be talking about today is
specifically how we can batch geometry
together meaning how we can render more
than one piece of geometry in a single
draw call at its core that is what
batching and batch rendering means to me
so let's break that down a little bit
what does it mean to be able to render
multiple pieces of geometry in a single
draw call why is that useful and what
does it even look like well
traditionally speaking the way that
we've been rendering pretty much
anything right now has been we built up
a vertex buffer of vertices and index
buffer with indices and then we render
that together using something like gel
draw elements and that is our draw
that's how we get something on the
screen if we want a different object or
if we want another square or rectangle
to appear on the screen we basically
repeat this process we can of course
reuse the same vertex buffer and index
buffer if our geometry doesn't change
for example if we just want a
differently shaped rectangle or another
rectangle on the screen in a different
position and then we just use uniform
matrices in our vertex shader to
actually position and potentially
transform that particular piece of
geometry that's great and all but what
happens if we want to render a lot of
things a huge amount of geometry now for
this video we're just gonna throw 3d
batching and all of that stuff out the
window we're just gonna focus on 2d
rendering here how do we render a large
amount of 2d quads or rectangles let's
start off with some examples so that we
can kind of understand what it is we're
trying to do let's say we're making a
2-d game it's a 2-d kind of top-down RPG
and we move around the world and the
world itself is made up of different
tiles grass tiles
tiles whatever a lot of tiny little
tiles something like a Harvest Moon
style game you know stardew valley
something like that now these games in a
lot of cases do in fact show the view
kind of from above and the camera can
actually get pretty far and we might
have a lot of different tiles on the
screen with our current kind of strategy
if we decide to render each tile as a
separate quad with a texture that's
gonna be kind of difficult it's gonna
get to the point where it's just not
gonna perform well because if we have
like hundreds if not thousands of tiles
in our world just being drawn one by one
as separate draw calls our GPU is not
gonna be able to keep up with that now
these days on modern hardware we can
absolutely on like a desktop computer
with a dedicated graphics card get away
with thousands of draw calls it's not as
big of a problem as say on mobile or as
it was in the past so I don't want to
like over over emphasize the fact that
this really is an issue but it's
absolutely not ideal especially for
something as simple as a quad if you're
drawing each quad individually
that's just inefficient and furthermore
of course as we do add more and more
quads or maybe we zoom out the camera
and we see more of that map our game may
actually start to drop frames because
it's just not going to be able to keep
up with the thousands of tiles that
we're trying to render another good
example is a particle system now I made
a game in an hour using hazel I'll have
the video linked up there in case you
haven't seen it and in that game I
needed to make some kind of particle
system so that we could have like fiery
particles and smoke particles and all of
that kind of stuff
now the way that I rendered those
particles there was just by using
individual quads with transforms simple
as that but again what happens if we
have thousands of these particles
because there's a huge particle system
what if we have particles in our 2-d
game that also has a huge tar map with
many clauses that we have to render we
might be looking at ten thousand draw
calls now and to add to that another
very popular example of rendering
rectangles is UI rendering what if we're
rendering text on our screen what if
there's like a quest to kind of journal
entry that just has paragraphs and
paragraphs of text the way that we
render text usually is by rendering each
character as a separate textured quad so
now we're looking at potentially a
thousand like tech
characters on the screen a particle
system going off in the background and
all of this on top of a level with a
thousand tiles on the screen at once
that's gonna be difficult to render even
on modern hardware but there is an
easier way or rather a more efficient
way and that is by batching or batch
rendering in a nutshell batching means
we batch together all of this geometry
into a single vertex buffer and index
buffer and then simply draw that once so
in other words instead of drawing one
square then another square then another
square all kind of individually we put
everything in together as if it was one
piece of geometry and then we just
simply render that once and that's it
the performance improvement with
batching together all of the kind of
scenarios that I just described is
absolutely huge in fact I really want to
actually do a benchmark of this in the
future just to show you guys how much of
an impact it actually has all right so
now that we know just how useful batch
rendering is how does it actually work
well let's take a look
so up until now one quad has always
resulted in one draw call which is an
issue because if we had a thousand of
these we'd get a thousand draw calls
which would be slow now realistically
1,000 probably isn't slow on your
hardware but the point is a lot of draw
calls is slow and we know that slow is
quite employed bad let's break down how
we would typically render a single quad
in OpenGL we would do something called a
vertex array which you could say
contains a vertex buffer and index
buffer and inside that we would have
four vertices and six indices which
makes up one quad the four vertices
would be here and then the indices of
each triangle being zero one two and
then two three zero that's our typical
setup for rendering a single quad and if
this is our screen with one quad here
and then another quad here the way that
we would achieve this is we would render
everything twice we'd render this vertex
array twice with a different transform
so we'd upload a uniform matrix into our
vertex shader which is our transform now
what if we could somehow take these two
quads and then put them into a single
vertex and index buffer combine them
into just one buffer let's try that
let's take this vertex array and expand
the vertex buffer so that it contains
two quads instead of one with the same
being done for the index buffer so if we
bring this down and look at the
equivalent what we actually have is two
of these the index buffer translates
into 0 1 2 2 3 0 for the first quad and
then 4 5 6 6 74 for the second quad so
we end up with 8 vertices and 12 indices
turtle 0 3 7 so what happens now is we
render this just once there are no
transforms at all and we get both of
these squares in a single draw call
which theoretically is faster
this of course does come with a bunch of
limitations because what controls the
position of this how do we set the
position of these quads we obviously
can't set a transform because that will
be a uniform matrix which we can only
change between draw calls not during a
draw call so what happens is this
position is taken from the vertex buffer
the buffer has the positions of each
quad you can still apply an offset to
the entire thing in the form
the transform if you like which is
basically what we would do for something
like a camera but the position of each
quad is inside the vertex buffer as
another example if you wanted to set the
color of each quad which is something
you might have done in the form of a
uniform before you can also put this
data into the vertex buffer so each
vertex would contain a color value which
you could then use inside your shader
well explore this more in future videos
so what does this mean for quads that
are constantly moving for example in a
particle system well this vertex buffer
has to become dynamic meaning that we
can stream data in every frame this is
extremely important because if you're
not dealing with the dynamic vertex
buffer then everything is essentially
static geometry and we might not want
that so I'm probably gonna end up making
a series of videos that kind of deal
with this because in this video I just
want to show you guys a really simple
example from the theory that we just
learned about to an actual
implementation that we're about to look
at something really simple to kind of
start off with and then in the future
we'll kind of keep adding features until
we can really just do anything we want
but with kind of rendering everything in
a single bash so now that we actually
know this theory and we know how it
works let's go ahead and transfer that
over to practice and actually take a
look at some code I'm using my OpenGL
library here for this example if you
guys haven't seen the videos that I've
made about that then definitely check
them out in the top right corner to
start off with let's take a look at a
super simple example of drawing a single
quad so for our initialization we're
loading a really basic shader here that
just positions and shades the quad with
a flat color then we have this float
array here which contains the vertex
positions of the quad just a one by one
quad that's centered at the origin then
we're creating a vertex array and a
vertex buffer which contains these
vertices as well as setting up the
vertex attribute pointer here so that we
can correctly access our vertex buffer
data inside our shader then we've got
our indices and our index buffer inside
our on update function which runs every
frame we're updating our camera
controller clearing the screen and
binding our shader
then we're setting a couple of uniforms
here the cameras view projection matrix
and a transform matrix for our quad
which in this case has a translation of
0 so it doesn't transform the quad at
all then we're binding our vertex array
and drawing the six indices that make up
our quad let's see what that looks like
okay cool so we have this white square
here and we can move the camera around
so how would we normally rent the two
quads using what we're used to well we
would simply issue another draw call but
we would set different transforms for
each draw using our shader uniforms so
what we're doing is rendering the same
geometry twice but with different
transforms and so we get two squares at
different positions on our screen but
how do we batch these together into a
single draw call like we talked about
let's come over here to the vertex
buffer what we need to do is duplicate
all of these vertices so that we've got
two squares inside our vertex buffer and
then apply this translation that we've
done by the transform uniform directly
into these vertex positions so you can
see that these are our resulting vertex
positions and just to be clear now we
have enough vertices to make up two
quads inside this one single vertex
buffer now we need to go down to our
index buffer and basically do the same
thing we need to add the indices that
make up this second quad so 4 5 6 6 7 4
finally we can go down to our rendering
code and get rid of our second draw call
and reset our translation back to zero
and instead of drawing 6 indices will
draw all 12 which make up our two quads
and that's it if I launch this now you
can see that I've got my two quads
rendering as they did before but this
time in a single draw call they're batch
together and that's pretty much it
that's how bad friend during works I
know that this is a really simple
example and you guys probably want to
see well how do we draw different colors
how do we draw textures how do we do all
of that stuff and in future videos as I
mentioned we will get into this I am
doing this little kind of batch
rendering miniseries so expect like
another video maybe in a week or so and
I'll just we'll just go on to the next
step of batch rendering do you guys have
any questions please leave them in the
comment section below don't forget to
like the video if you did like it and
also I do have a patreon patron force
after the Cherno please help support
this channel if you did enjoy this video
and you found it helpful and I will see
you guys next time goodbye
[Music]